how did they cast this whole crew yeah
okay so we need like a great very
handsome dude with like a giant day and
it's gonna be in every shot yeah and you
have one line sure man i'm there yeah
that guy did have one line he comes in
remember that scene when cassie's in the
bathtub yeah yeah and he sits down he's
like hey you're really hot but i'm still
gonna take a [ __ ] your agents reach out
and they're like hey we have this
awesome roll for you they like really
want you that scene shocked me because
like i don't know where i thought it
went when you're [ __ ] but like not
there just having this conversation
where someone was like i some girl was
like i thought that guy's like held it
or like pushed it back or something yeah
we let it
let it stir the pot that goes in the
water right and then down down the
toilet yeah it gets in the way the ocean
yeah the ocean yeah
finding nemo has a new friend yeah
that's the hardest part about a guy when
you take a [ __ ] is pulling your penis
all the way out and i fold mine up
yeah
yeah
i had a friend in high school she had a
little brother and no one told her that
guys didn't like wipe after they pee so
she taught him as like a child to like
wipe yeah after he peed wipe his dick
kind of polite like it just dabs it like
a
like nice i have done that before yeah i
have too i don't know if i can say this
but like
that's a hipaa violation whatever do you
like do you like euphoria love do you
yeah you're not nothing [ __ ] happens
it's because you didn't watch episode
four because of your youtube tv yeah
yeah i know wait i will text you my hbo
password please yeah can i have that
yeah it's my dad's but he'll love
it drops in the 90 minutes that it's
playing the minute that it's done and
actually during the show it's over on
twitter you can't get on twitter until
you've watched the next episode
and so i'm like i have to watch this
thing and i don't know if i'd like the
show if i just like being a part of
something like every episode is like a
trailer for the next yeah that's that's
why i hate it because it just nothing
happens
everything is some crazy artsy montage
yeah this season is pissing me off
because it's like they're taking the
little moments that felt good like
sprinkled in in season one and now it's
just like
large portions and i'm like all right
it's just yeah there's 19 short films
it's the majority of the show now yeah
with little plot uh things in in between
them feels like they forward the plot
like a little by little and then like
right as they're doing that and you like
get into it it'll be like some weird
artsy
segment of rue being like so you want to
be a drug dealer and she's teaching the
class and it's like well come on yeah i
like have really started to lean into it
as symbolic a lot of the scenes now are
like basically what i picked up on this
on this new episode like the biggest
thing that i picked up besides like
like
beyond like the oh this is a
example of gaslighting or like whatever
like yeah there's like deeper things
where this episode cody this is not
integral to watching this episode rue is
usually a narrator and she doesn't
narrate the entire episode it's like the
most chaotic like everyone like [ __ ] is
like falling apart
and she is not narrated once and it's i
think and this is not integral also i
think i really don't care you can ruin
it
yes this is not integral the main
character died yeah
i mean i have a theory i have a theory i
think she's either dead or she's od'd
and yeah i think that's not i think
that's just what happened no but my new
theory
my new theory that i was leading up to
was
was that she's been dead the whole time
and that's why she's omnipresent can
narrate everything
no
like
you're not so sure you're not convinced
you mean this is like keep in mind like
theories aren't necessarily 100 facts
i'm just i know what the definition of
theory is
thank you
so much for
telling me that
he's going to say he stepped out of
1940. he's like you can't read
you're a woman let me explain to you the
concept of theory well she was like well
you're wrong
she might be you like she's dead in the
future and telling the whole story
of like this was
an experience or she's truly like
sitting on a cloud success and everyone
is seeing her sixth sense type [ __ ]
she's been dead the whole time right
you've said
and all the dicks are fake i looked it
up i don't know she face [ __ ] dominic
vikes so i don't know if that could be
oh yo
spoiler not an integral everybody
everybody is an integral part that's
like that's my gripe with this we're not
even no integral parts oh there's an
integral part no that's that's exactly
what i'm saying only one thing happened
on this episode no there was the whole
thing with nate's dad
that's the one thing that happened i'm
loving his whole storyline bruce
probably dead sorry cody everyone's
cheating on rue the whole cassie thing
was so good and so related
what happens with cassie why don't you
just [ __ ] say it now well she just
like drinks herself half to death and
then gets in the hot tub no no no the
scene between her and nate when they're
yelling when she goes
okay
i was like oh
sorry oh
this is like
crazy it's like that was my favorite i
rewinded but then when it's maddie's
birthday and everybody's together she's
like so miserable and she drinks and
drinks and drinks and then gets in the
hot tub with everybody and just like
pukes on like every single oh let's go
and it is just so chaotic and crazy i
don't need to watch that and like i feel
like the only relatable part of the
whole show is just like her no no
spiraling and crying and crying yeah
that i'm
that
like
yeah
that makes that make sense to me
i think you need to watch just for the
the one other thing that happens i think
that's like no that's that's
that alone i was watching
the episode and i was like
what the hell the [ __ ] is the point of
this and then it got to that yeah and i
went whoa
yeah that was so that was that was so it
was like it gives me chills i think
because there's like we're losing the
plot and i think like a lot of people
are like what now what the [ __ ] is
happening like rue is the main character
i'm like no i think the whole point is
that everybody's gonna go through their
own storyline yeah and we're gonna have
six different
like spin-offs well i think what they're
right doing right now is they're setting
up for season three season four season
five season six yeah i see
oh sorry no no please bro go no i saw
this tick tock that was like a list of
like unresolved things that have
happened like who knows where the tape
is like the third like the third son
like where did mckay go and it was just
like a full like three notes pages worth
of unresolved things and i think that's
why people are also so pissed off like
so many loose ends like you're going in
so many different directions yeah also
that the girl cat oh yeah the cam girl
cat she got in a fight with the director
sam levinson on set and he cut like all
of her lines so
and so her like boyfriend is basically
being like written out of the show
because she he's just an extension of
her i am that's a storyline what was the
what was the fight about like did they
say anything i think there's been like
loki like an issue with him over
sexualizing a lot of the characters uh
and she was like this is unnecessary
like it doesn't need to happen he's like
i'm the director that's my understanding
but i don't
he's like no i mean
there needs to be a dick in this scene
after the 19th um sydney sweeney needs
yes sydney sweeney needs to pull her
chest out yeah
yeah that part is getting a little a
little much yeah i mean just everyone's
naked all the time yeah that's classic
it's just like that's what high school
is yeah it's high school man yeah i was
naked you didn't go to the party and i
mean i was just thinking
no i will say euphoria reminds me
specifically of this moment in high
school where there's like some girls she
was like popular she's like kind of new
to our school there's like some big
parties she went to
the school on monday i'll never forget
this this crazy ass kid he like walks up
i was like one of my classes and we had
a little group in there oh yeah dude she
came to this party this weekend dude she
got so drunk she [ __ ] herself and then
everyone just called her like doo doo
pants for the rest of the year
when that happens damn but i'm like that
felt like i'm like yeah was it brook
trying to get out of a situation where
she blocked somebody i was just gonna
say was it me
am i doo doo pants
uh this euphoria plot right there yeah
everyone calls me doo doo pants what
they don't know is cut i block this guy
because i hate his content i [ __ ] how
to [ __ ] yourself at a party well damn
yeah i don't know we'll we'll see how
this season ends up i'm i'm gonna
withhold my judgment